[Music]
even as the votes were being counted the
Belfast weekend becomes a pageant of
marches and parades a short physical
distance and also worlds apart a
Catholic Community March
and this the first of the Summer's
Protestant parades not much attention is
paid to the election results
so maybe this will be a kick in the
teeth that maybe the up need to come in
and get back to work it's election that
happens you know people think I have to
vote I have to make a change and then
things happen and you do sort of think
well what was the point in that local
council elections these may be but that
sense of apathy extends to almost half
the electorate who chose not to vote it
reflects frustration at the Democratic
unionist party's ongoing boycott of
power sharing in the Stormont assembly
the dup fears post-brexit trading
Arrangements will erode Northern
Ireland's ties with the British Mainland
and the latest election is unlikely to
change that I think that a lot of people
will look at it and say the dep
possession is holding as holding strong
and and the public are behind them and
what they're doing so you know we're
we're comfortable with the possession
that we have the party's position means
frustration both for the Republican Shin
Fein now the biggest party in Northern
Ireland and for those forging a third
way the alliance party trying to capture
the non-aligned center ground we've got
to talk about reform we've got to talk
about how we fix it it's not fair that
one team can take the ball away and no
one else is allowed to play there has to
change so that we can all get in and
deliver and stop that apathy it was just
weeks ago that the world watched as
Northern Ireland marked the 25th
anniversary of a good Friday peace
agreement but a quarter of a century and
a few weeks on and not only are the
signs of sectarian divide still plain to
see but the politics put in place by
that agreement just don't seem to be
working
it may yet be months before devolved
government is allowed to resume in the
meantime engagement and faith in
politics is being put to the test is
there major disconnect between parties
of all sections and been able to reach a
large core of the population in Northern
Ireland and that is worrying because the
more that goes on the more the victors
are actually going to be less
representative of the people of Northern
Ireland
a non-functioning executive an
unrepresentative political Elite another
election over in Northern Ireland
without resulting in change Jonah Hall
Al Jazeera Belfast
[Music]